the Catholic Church scandal abused
sexual sexual abuse scandal rather has
reached the highest levels of the
Vatican overnight with charges against a
top official his name is Cardinal George
pally faces multiple criminal charges in
Australia for alleged sexual assault
that was committed allegedly decades ago
the Cardinal is a top adviser to Pope
Francis who has promised zero tolerance
of sex abuse Pell will take a leave of
absence while he fights the charges this
morning Cardinal Pell says he is
innocent
Seth donuts in room Rome with the
allegations rocking the Vatican today
Seth good morning good morning in this
elite group of Cardinals considered the
so-called princes of the church Cardinal
Pell is at the very top considered one
of the closest advisors to Pope Francis
so these charges this morning are
sending shockwaves through the Catholic
Church the 76 year old Cardinal was
reflective but forceful this morning
railing against what he said was nearly
two years of relentless character
assassination I'm innocent of these
charges they are false the whole idea of
sexual abuse is abhorrent to me
Australian police did not provide any
specific details of the multiple charges
of sexual assault Cardinal George Pell
has been in charge of reforming church
finances but for years has faced
allegations that he did not properly
deal with clergy sex abuse in Australia
he was questioned by a commission
investigating the church's response to
abuse via videolink
from Rome with the experience of 40
years later certainly the experience of
40 years later hell told reporters this
morning that he has been in regular
contact with Pope Francis the Holy
Father regularly informed who has
granted him leave to return to Australia
for his day in court in mid-july how big
of a blow are these charges to the
Catholic
this is a major blow Robert Mickens with
Catholic publication Lacroix
international has been covering the
Vatican for 25 years you have to
understand is the Vatican language is
always going to be very much more
conciliatory Cardinal fellow said the
Pope has given him a leave of absence
it's very likely that the hope stood him
down and that leave of absence according
to the Vatican is effective immediately
a leave of absence is quite significant
for a priest it is even more serious for
a Cardinal and for such a close friend
and adviser of Pope Francis it is a
shock Nora all right Seth Doane in Rome
thank you so much